bonjour québec merci de répondre à nos
questions ce matin sur arte france 400
millions d'euros supplémentaires soit
6,4 milliards au total
ce n'est pas suffisant selon vous
pourtant 6,4 milliards ça reste une
somme importante non oui tout à fait
vous avez raison c'est pas c'est pas un
peu d'argent que le ministre met sur la
table
néanmoins c'est loin de pouvoir remplir
le cahier de revendications des
personnels hospitaliers qui je le
rappelle sans temps en mouvement depuis
de nombreuses années un principalement
depuis 2017 2018 pour les ehpad et puis
depuis l'année dernière pour les
hôpitaux mais 6 milliards ça ne contente
pas parce que ça ne couvre même pas la
revendication principale de 300 euros
pour tous les personnels et je le
rappelle c'est 300 euros ne sont que le
rattrapage de l'inflation sur les 13
dernières années donc ce n'est pour nous
que le dû de ce que le gouvernement dans
le cadre de la politique d'austérité
qu'il mène depuis des années et les
prédécesseurs avant lui ont fait subir
aux personnels hospitaliers donc voilà
il faudra que le gouvernement passe dans
la négociation par le fait d'augmenter
un tout petit peu le volume d'argent
qu'il met sur la table pour que nous
puissions trouver un accord alors
justement vous venez de parler un des
300 euros d'augmentation que vous
souhaiter pour tous au final ça se
chiffre à combien et comment financer ce
que vous demandez aurait coûté je crois
que sur le financement c'est le travail
que nous essayons de faire aujourd'hui
avec le gouvernement il faut environ 6 8
milliards pour faire 300 euros pour tous
les personnels de la fonction publique
le ministre
au milieu du ségur est venu rajouter
tous les infirmiers et les aides
soignantes du secteur privé sa porte
l'addition pour rester à 300 euros à 9
milliards 8
donc c'est une décision du ministre nous
en avons pris acte
maintenant il faut que le ministre
trouve les moyens budgétaires de telle
manière à mettre les 9 milliards sur la
table il faut faire attention aux effets
d'annoncé parce que lorsque le ministre
dit qu'il a 6 8 milliards d'argent à
mettre sur la table pour les
hospitaliers ce n'est pas en 2020 ce
n'est pas en 2021 mais ça ne sera
effectif
le jeu des enveloppes budgétaires en
2022 donc attention aux épées d'annonce
il n'y a pas autant d'argent tout de
suite sur la table pour les hospitaliers
alors justement on parle d'argent libyen
vers ans doit obtenir de nouveaux
arbitrages financiers de l'elysée selon
force ouvrière et revenir vers vous dans
quel état d'esprit est ce que vous êtes
et ce que vous êtes confiant justement
pour obtenir cet argent les 9 milliards
8 dont vous parlez si l'on combine à la
voile à la fois le public et le privé
si nous avions dû au regard des
premières propositions du ministre faire
ce que nous avions à faire et nous
serions partis de négociations parce que
les propositions du ministre était
tellement basque c'était une insulte
hospitalier mais parce que le secteur a
besoin a clairement besoin que l'on
trouve un accord pour que les personnels
retrouve une qualité de travail au
niveau d'une satisfaction qui leur
permettent de retrouver le plaisir
d'aller travailler parce que les malades
ont besoin de retrouver des services
avec des nombres de personnel suffisant
et bien tout cela fait que nous nous
sommes restés dans la salle
malgré les provocations du gouvernement
sur des propositions extrêmement basses
nous étions de l'ordre de 35 euros pour
tous les personnels en début de
négociation
voilà nous sommes restés parce que nous
sommes les syndicats responsables parce
qu'il nous faut un accord dans l'intérêt
des français et parce que je les dis au
ministre les français le soir à 20
heures lorsqu'ils ont applaudi les
personnels hospitaliers tous les
personnels hospitaliers ils ont donné un
blanc-seing au ministre pour dire au
ministre vous pouvez y aller vous pouvez
mettre de l'argent sur la table
nous sommes d'accord avec le fait de
mettre de l'argent pour les hôpitaux
alors le ministre a un mandat clair et
nous ne comprenons pas que les
technocrates sont toujours encore avec
la calculette en main à vouloir
grappiller des millions par ci des
millions par là et ne pas donner
satisfaction aux personnels hospitaliers
10 est regrettable oui pardon
didier vereecke à côté de vous on voit
edouard philippe
on sait que le secteur de la santé doit
prendre fin à la mi juillet mais il y
aura peut-être un nouveau premier
ministre un nouveau gouvernement est ce
que ça peut faire bouger les lignes
selon vous écoutez je un jour je n'en
sais rien je pense qu'il ya une
continuité aujourd'hui au niveau de
l'état qui qui est en place nous nous
espérons que ça ne va pas trop impacter
le ségur même si nous avons déjà eu la
surprise hier d'avoir la dernière
réunion de négociation qui a été annulé
nous savons que la réunion conclusive
qu'il doit avoir lieu aujourd'hui est
également reportée parce que iain
s'entrechoquer deux séquences politiques
qui ont une interaction l'une envers
l'autre
si aujourd'hui edouard philippe dépose
la démission du gouvernement
nous savons qu'il n'ya plus le ministre
de la santé donc il ne peut pas y avoir
de proximité dans le ségur jusqu'à ce
que le prochain ministre soit soit se
retrouve dans la nouvelle équipe du lys
donc voila nous allons patienter parce
que voilà nous avons l'habitude de ça et
nous pensons que la semaine prochaine
eh ben les réunions reprendront et que
nous arriverons à une conclusion
rapidement sa nou la fé remercier didier
mérite d'avoir répondu à nos questions à
tôt ce matin je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la branche santé
de force ouvrière